le 30 septembre
1955 Adjamé
est né une lionne
une guerrière une Amazon
son nom c'est une triaison et c'est mon
inspiration
à 3 ans elle perd sa mère
à 5 ans elle perd son père
et elle se retrouve toute seule et elle
plonge dans une misère tellement extrême
pour la surnomme Jésus-Christ black
et blanc
Côte d'Ivoire
veut dire femme donc Jésus-Christ en
femme parce que c'est une femme de
misère
et à 5 ans on la livre en tant que
servante à Bingerville et nous parlons
là des années 60 donc Bingerville est un
grande ville de la Côte d'Ivoire
maintenant étant en fait un petit
village et brillé dans le temps que
personne ne connaissait à condition que
vous soyez briller donc elle devient
servante là-bas jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans
et à 10 ans elle a un grand frère de qui
elle entend parler maintenant qui lui
dit mais viens je vais te mettre à
l'école parce qu'il a été instituteur et
donc il a mis à l'école et parce qu'elle
avait cette rage de vouloir aller à
l'école elle a commencé à gravir
rapidement les échelons et être sautait
même les classes et donc elle a rattrapé
les enfants de sa catégorie d'âge et
pour pouvoir continuer ses études parce
que elle a rattrapé elle était
maintenant adolescente et donc pour
continuer ses études je sais pas si vous
connaissez Abinader
les faiseurs de chewing-gum dans le
temps et en ce moment là il venait de
commencer après je suis ville je crois
vers la zone industrielle et donc elle
partait à binader parce qu'ils avaient
des chewing-gums qui faisaient qui ne
marche qui n'ont pas réussi donc on les
jetait derrière dans la poubelle donc
elle partait et ramassait ses
chewing-gums là et elle est vendait et
c'est avec ça qu'elle mangeait elle est
sa grande sœur et c'est avec ça qu'elle
a pu aller à l'école donc elle est après
ces études secondaires elle a eu un
diplôme au cours locaux de stéréo
dactylographie je sais même plus si ça
existe ce genre de truc donc voilà comme
ça elle a rencontré mon père et s'est
mariée elle a eu 6 enfants dont je fais
partie
et voilà comment la misère parce que
quelqu'un qui sait toujours battu toute
sa vie tu estimes que on te mariant la
vie serait un peu plus rose ben non 6
enfants deux petits salaires de
fonctionnaires on sait très bien combien
les fonctionné gagnent madame la
ministre et donc c'est là qu'a commencé
le plus difficile 6 enfants et non
seulement c'est pas de six enfants
qu'elle s'occupe mais nous sommes en
Afrique on s'occupe aussi de la famille
élargie elle s'occupe aussi des
orphelins parce qu'elle a été orpheline
elle s'occupe des veuves parce qu'elle a
cette compassion pour les veuves et donc
on se retrouve là dans des maisons de
deux chambres salon très souvent pour la
plupart de mon adolescence avec ses
enfants avec des cousins des cousines
sans compter les bonnes sans compter les
orphelins sans compter les vœux sans
compter les personnes avec qui elle
faisait la prière et la maison était
tout le temps chargée voilà et c'était
difficile mon frère est là il peut
témoigner que il y a eu des moments
homogène fois par jour et c'était à midi
et c'était un placardi de 100 francs
pour 6 enfants donc il y avait la femme
d'un ministre dans le temps il n'était
pas encore ministre qui vend des plats
Ali à tout bon sur la route et donc on
partage ses plaques à distance ensemble
et on mangeait voilà ça a été difficile
il peut témoigner aussi que on attendait
qu'il pleut pour recueillir l'eau de
pluie pour se laver donc c'était pénible
c'était une vie très difficile et moi à
l'âge 19 ans à l'âge de 20 ans pardon
j'étais en deuxième année d'université
en médecine à l'université Langueux à
brogua d'Adjamé
et on a vu que l'année université allait
probablement une année blanche parce
qu'il y avait des activités politiques
aussi bien que les activités de la
fessée donc elle a pris ses petites
économies et elle m'a envoyé aux
États-Unis voilà et bien avant que
j'aille aux États-Unis à l'âge de 7 ans
déjà elle m'avait mis dans le commerce
qu'elle faisait parce que elle vendait
un peu de tout elle avait qui elle avait
des restaurants elle avait travaillé à
la RTI en tant que simple secrétaire
mais elle avait même un maquis au RFK
qui est un point de restaurant à la RTI
la radio diffusion télévisée ivoirienne
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas et donc
je vendais là-bas dans son maquis on
vendait des oranges je vendais des
oranges depuis tout petit devant la
cantine de la RTI je vendais des
chemises et des cravates au journaliste
et des employés de la RTI donc j'ai
grandi pratiquement à la RTI et je suis
content de voir certaines journalistes
me reconnaître aujourd'hui et ça a été
difficile mais en tant que petite fille
je ne voyais pas sa comme une difficulté
pour moi c'était le combat de ma mère et
je partage avec elle ce combat et à 10
ans j'ai commencé à avoir des beignets
sur la route on habitait en poteau ou
pourtant en ce moment un village est
brillé parce qu'on en avait pas les
moyens donc c'est retrouver un bouton et
je vendais des beignets à l'âge de 10
ancien de pendant que j'étais président
de la coopérative scolaire je vendrai
aussi des beignets voilà donc j'ai vendu
tout sauf mon corps mais j'ai tout vendu
je trouve
merci et donc quand je suis arrivé aux
États-Unis à l'âge de 20 ans avec les
efforts de ma mère un jour j'apprenais
l'anglais parce qu'il faut faire deux
semestres d'anglais on s'est passé le
tofun donc un jour j'ai vu je suis allé
à jeter à d'abord
Atlanta ensuite je suis parti à une je
sais pas trop aimé Atlanta dans le temps
donc je suis ensuite parti à université
ça c'est narlington donc je suis parti à
YouTube
et là j'ai vu des jeunes de l'université
qui jouent au basket et je dis mais ah
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas joué au
bas c'est parce que si j'ai joué en
équipe nationale j'ai en première
division j'ai intégré l'équipe nationale
à l'âge de 16 ans dans le temps j'étais
la plus jeune qui a jamais recruté en
équipe nationale de Côte d'Ivoire en
première division ensuite je joue à la
SEC mimosa et je joue à l'Abidjan basket
au club avant de partir aux États-Unis
donc je dis bon je vais aller jouer un
peu avec les garçons et quand j'ai joué
avec les garçons de l'équipe de
l'université
le coach ma vie m'a dit my god vous
jouez très bien donc il a appelé
immédiatement un autre coach d'une autre
université parce qu'il a dit notre
niveau est trop bas pour ton niveau donc
il a appelé le coach d'une autre
université qu'on appelle Survivor City
c'est à tôle ça Oklahoma et le lendemain
il est venu me voir jouer immédiatement
il me dit on prend l'avion il faut que
on aille te voir jouer là-bas donc je
suis parti et dès que j'ai joué ils me
disent bon te signe une bourse d'études
donc tu vas absolument rien payer et
c'est en première division ainsi d'abord
et donc c'est le la compétition
universitaire la plus élevée là-bas et
donc je dis d'accord donc ils ont pris
mes études en charge je ne peux
absolument rien pour moi c'était le
Dream country et c'est de là qu'on va WW
NBA donc vraiment je comptais jouer en
double NBA et là parce que je suis
tellement forte tellement tellement
forte qu'ils ont commencé à mettre deux
personnes pour défendre sur moi et avec
ça les blessures ont commencé donc en
plein match j'ai qui est carrément tombé
qui balançait comme ça et j'ai perdu
l'usage de la main pendant deux mois
mais il fallait revenir parce que la
compétition le demande donc on te remet
rapidement sur pied là on s'en fout du
reste donc je suis revenu je me suis
fait mal au genou il fallait me faire
opérer et là ça commençait très grave
donc je dis je vais plus jouer parce que
je risquais d'être paralysé et il y a
une autre université en californique me
dit non on va vous prendre avec vos
blessures on va manage oui on va gérer
ça ne vous en faites pas donc là moi je
vais en Californie pour jouer à 20h
University où nous avons été aussi
champion parce que on a été non
seulement champion de notre conférence
qui est le mythe continent confrères
mais on a aussi on a aussi participé au
West and Final Four qui est vraiment un
big dire là-bas donc je suis parti en
Californie j'ai joué là-bas aussi on a
été championne là-bas et après ça j'ai
eu tellement de de pardon de angelerie
donc j'ai tellement de blessures à la
tête au cerveau parce que je me cognais
je tombais c'était vraiment agressif que
il m'a fallu arrêter carrément de jouer
donc j'ai perdu ma bourse d'étude et
j'ai tout perdu voilà mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire je suis tombé dans la
dépression totale et il a mentionné
Serge Le Sergio et mon grand frère
depuis longtemps depuis une vingtaine
d'années donc il a été celui-là qui m'a
dit mais il faut te relever donc j'ai
pris un boulot à un mode donc imaginez
une petite fille qui est brillante à
l'école toujours première de sa classe
depuis le CPA jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
reçu des prix ici encore d'Ivoire le
prix cher à son de toutes les écoles de
de la commune de Cocody en dictée donc
je suis brillante et je me retrouve là
en train de travailler dans le molle en
train de maquiller des gens mais il
fallait le faire et je me suis dit si je
le fais il faut que je sois la première
donc pour moi c'est l'excellence donc
tout ce que je fais ou rien d'autre et
donc j'ai fait mes preuves comme ça et
quand les plats possibilités est venu
d'avoir mes papiers que j'ai eu mes
papiers je suis retourné à l'école et là
il fallait que je prouve que je suis
aussi intelligente donc j'ai
immédiatement fini mon Bachelor j'ai
entamé avec mon MBA et là j'ai fini j'ai
fini avec une autre tellement parfaite
qu'on m'a donné une médaille d'or à sa
fille université
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite j'ai commencé à je suis
rentrée dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
après le make-up je suis rentré dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais
laissez-moi ajouter que pendant que je
faisais le maquillage j'étais tellement
bien qu'on m'appelait un jour vous
maquillez une célébrité et je me suis
présenté là-bas ne sachant pas qui
c'était j'avais devant moi 8 les Houston
donc
donc j'ai maquillé Whitney Houston j'ai
maquille Erika Badoo j'ai maquillé
madame Gbagbo dans le temps qu'elle
était venue Atlanta j'ai aussi maquillé
ainsi Wilson des Supremes donc parce que
c'était la meilleure dans ce que je
faisais donc je suis rentrée dans merci
je suis rentré dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique et après ça je suis allée
travailler pour American caisse socialdi
et le bill Gates Foundation donc j'ai eu
l'opportunité de rencontrer le
milliardaire Bill Gates et j'ai commencé
à faire mes preuves j'ai été directrice
aussi à Orange aux États-Unis avec 46
employés partout dans le monde je suis
rentré ensuite dans la Silicon Valley et
je fais mes preuves et là-bas j'ai reçu
plein de prix j'ai reçu des prix
d'excellence de toute la compagnie de
Abbot du sillo de la compagnie pour le
travail que je fais j'ai reçu aussi le
premier prix le clinique Costa Airworld
à gilier qui va aussi les les produits
pharmaceutiques pour pour prévenir la
séropositivité la trans de ce virus là
j'ai travaillé là-bas ils ont dû créer
un prix spécial pour moi parce que
j'étais tellement excellent dans ce que
je faisais et j'ai pu positionner cette
compagnie à l'échelle mondiale comme le
sponsor de choix donc et créer un prix
spécialement là-bas et donc c'est comme
ça j'ai aussi travaillé pour fizer
jusqu'à ce que j'en arrive là voilà donc
je suis je voulais vous dire simplement
aujourd'hui qu'on peut partir de rien on
peut partir de zéro où on mange placali
100 francs une fois par jour on peut
avoir des rêves et tout peut chambouler
d'un moment à l'autre mais comment
est-ce qu'on fait après ça c'est là le
plus important votre réaction quand vous
vous avez ce genre de truc en face de
vous donc comment vous réagissez c'est
là le plus important il faut se relever
et là je veux je veux dire à toutes ces
personnes aujourd'hui qui sont
découragés parce que il y a des gens qui
sont pas nécessairement à zéro mais qui
sont un certain niveau dans la vie où
ils sont découragés et vous avez ce
plateau là que vous avez atteint et vous
vous dites oh c'est fini je suis trois
jeux pour retourner à l'école moi je
suis en train de finir une thèse en
pioche dis je suis en train de faire un
pied sur leadership et à 44 quand
j'estime que je suis encore très jeune
et pourquoi pas ajouter un autre piège
dit donc je suis en train de le faire je
veux me former je vais être la meilleure
je ne peux pas être la meilleure partout
mais je serai la meilleure dans ce que
je fais et c'est pour ça que je suis là
pour vous encourager
soyez les meilleurs dans tout ce que
vous faites partir vous êtes il faut
qu'il y ait des prix même s'il n'existe
pas des prix il faut qu'on puisse créer
ces prix là pour vous parce que vous
êtes les meilleurs vous êtes les
meilleurs ça m'a fait tellement plaisir
d'entendre tous ces témoignages les
femmes sont puissantes les femmes ont
les femmes ont une puissance
et donc moi aux États-Unis ça peut être
facile parce que vous savez il y a le
racisme je suis africaine donc j'ai un
gros accent africain quand je parle
l'anglais parce que je suis parti à
l'âge de 20 ans mais ça ne m'a pas
arrêté aujourd'hui je suis la seule
noire mais la seule noire africaine dans
l'équipe exécutive de la compagnie et ça
a été mon cas dans la plupart des
compagnies où je suis passée
et donc je suis là pour vous montrer je
suis les hommes palpable je suis le
modèle pour vous dire que c'est possible
il faut oser il faut rêver il faut se
battre tous les jours aujourd'hui ma
mère qui était Jésus Christ blanc
aujourd'hui elle est américaine
[Applaudissements]
elle est américaine elle peut être fière
de moi et vraiment elle s'est battu tous
les jours elle n'a pas abandonné elle
s'est battue tous les jours pour que je
sois où je suis et c'est elle mon
inspiration je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]